[Musik]
auf und davon präsentiert von
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Edelweiß Island 22 Uhr ausflugszeit hier
zu
Lande das gchaff wenn wir mal für dann
freuen wir dass
das
Auswanderer Steff Felix und seine Frau
Isabelle sind unterwegs zum Outdoor
wellness ist heißer Wasserfall Strom
schon
g so cool aber das ist halt wenn nicht
windet um die 40° hat das
[Musik]
Wasser auf Mallorca übernimmt der
erfahrene Gastronom otma gemper mit
seinem Partner Gabor ballock ein
Restaurant Corina die bisherige
Besitzerin hilft die erste Saison mit
die panzen vorne diemich mit habe ich
gerade dreimal gesagt die kommen auf dem
Balkon
kaputt nach und nach soll sie das Lokal
an otma
übergeben aber schon kurz nach der
Eröffnung droht der Traum zu platzen
wegen gesundheitlicher Probleme nimmt
sich OT eine Auszeit in der Schweiz das
ist sch se mehr 20 J Traum das
Restaurant in Mallorca
das er lässt sich nicht unterkriegen und
kommt gestkt mit nach Mallorca zurück
ich freue mich wieder hier zu sein dann
schaffen wir das zusammen einfach vier
Mädels wirkommen jetzt gleich was zu
essen und ich achte es aber gerade neu
die müssen jetzt erstmal begrüßt werden
die Stimmung zwischen Corin und den
Auswanderern aber ist zunehmend
angespannt schön möch schon etwas
trinken Ciao ein Jahr ist es her dass
Familie charna die Schweiz verlassen hat
in Florida sollen die ferienträume
Alltag werden
imau
sie investieren in mehrere
Immobilien das Haus in Alligator point
bauen sie zu einem beachhaus
um
aber auch mit dem selbst renovierten
Wohnwagen auf ihrem Gelände wollen Sie
Geld verdienen die Fahrt mit dem
Schulbus ist das tägliche Highlight von
Tochter Lil Rose schon bald darf auch
Schwester in den
Kindergarten die Nordlichter gehören zum
neuen Leben von Isabelle und steef Felix
ihre Ferien Lodge in Island wollen sie
um drei tiny Häuser erweitern die
Fundamente sind die erste große
Herausforderung eine Bautruppe aus der
Schweiz stellt die Häuser auf den
Innenausbau stemmen die beiden über
Monate allein der schutzf mit mir
ja
parallel dazu der
Gästebetrieb noch aber fehlt etwas
Entscheidendes Apartment Wasser für
die kein Wasser nach einem
arbeitsreichen Winter erschließen sie
die Quelle ob sie aber genug Wasser
bringt ist
unklar es ist Sommer in
Island noch immer ist die hangy Lodge am
Ufer des Lager float eine Baustelle der
Gästebetrieb läuft auf
Hochtouren
[Gelächter]
schwi tausen los läuft die
Waschmaschine die Bett und freewäsche
wollten sie eigentlich in eine Reinigung
geben doch diese musste den Betrieb
einstellen
das Problem ist dass die wöscheret ist
und auch die einzige ist quasi das und
die näch der
nächervice ist einfach anderthalb Stunde
weg und das lohnt sich dann für einfach
nicht immerhin während der Schulferien
haben sie
Unterstützung die Tochter einer
Nachbarin hilft beim Putzen
mit
das Reinigen der Apartments ist zur
hauptsison um einiges aufwendiger als
gedacht ich meine mit das
hat das ist nicht Problem aber wenn
natürlich jetzt h
dazu ja dann dasmen oder zwischen
Checkout und Checkin bleiben ihnen nur
wenige
Stunden als gelernter Steinmetz ist es
Steff gewohnt
anzupacken den kompletten Innenausbau
der Tiny Häuser haben die hauswanderer
selbst
gemacht Wände verkleiden plätli legen
Möbel montieren selbst vor
Sanitärarbeiten schreckt Steff nicht
zurück seit einem Jahr sind Sie dran
permanent ja glaub hauptslich
fr wenn das Projekt
fertig
W und während Bau und Gästebetrieb nicht
schon genug kam tausasser Steff noch mit
einem weiteren
Projekt ja manä Pflanzen was sie nicht
fre aber auch
nicht die vi bä in der W
ja das ist jetzt schy belast die hüse
fertig machen g W
voll und jetzt die
Woche B aber ja für die nächste
Generation
gemacht ein Häuschen weiter ist Isabelle
im endsport in zwei Tagen schon stehen
die ersten Gäste vor der
Tür
noch aber ist nicht alles
fertig heiß heiß heiß wo h ger ja
da so
[Musik]
ja und
dann
steckdoseleid
ein weiteres Mal ist Teamwork
gefragt es gibt schwiig GI die gich
meinft zu dass dieidech plötzlich nicht
realisierbar ist es einfach nicht geht
das ist tatsälich Island Kompromiss wir
im Dorf ein baulad und was es h ja und
gut und ich hoffe der G g WE
war dass er jetzt silberrig müsst se und
ja das erlichtert eigentlich ein sehr
viel gut und da jetzt schon super
[Musik]
nein
morning morning
Timing Auswanderer mario hat sich mit
Nachbar snor verabredet s soll Mario
helfen eine Glastüre einzubauen Inas
neuestem
renovationsobjekt in die Immobilie die
Famil
ch vor ganz
furchtbar oh mein Gott und das
und aber mE kein Problem
Problemes in der Tat Familie Char
scheint vieles richtig zu machen das
mobile home in Alligator point haben sie
inzwischen fertig umgebaut als Wild West
Beach houseus vermieten sie es an
Touristen auch ihr Apartment am Ufer des
lockne River ist gut
gebucht
ja das Haus in carabell besteht aus zwei
getrennten Wohnungen der Preis für
Schweizer Verhältnisse ein
Schnäppchen der
baust das ist die
woh das Verbinden das ganze das
diefangsidee bis Kollege gefunden
ne wenn das für einzeln vermen und ja
auf der Idee sind wir jetzt auch Hieben
ja ich glaub das ist g dann h Einzel
Einheit
woich Familie t ist gerade
direkt während Mario die groben Arbeiten
erledigt kümmert sich Melan um die
Details die gelernte quf ist für die
Ausstattung der Apartments
verantwortlich
ja alte Häuser günstig erwerben Sie
renovieren und vermieten oder mit Gewinn
weiterverkaufen das ist das Geschäft der
[Musik]
Rheintaler
für den Einbau der Zentner schweren Türe
kommt noch ein weiterer Helfer
vorbei durch ihre offene Art haben
charers schnell Freunde
gefunden gegen ist bekannt dass maninand
hilft man muss Hal da bereit z zum zum
auch mal Helfer oder und denen sie auch
wieder mal got
okay
in Zukunft will Mario jemanden anstellen
der ihm beim Bauen helfft doch noch hat
er niemanden
gefunden ja ja
ja
ja 45 Minuten Fahrt sind es von der
Baustelle in carabell bis zum
Kindergarten Tochter rubisu wartet schon
auf Melanie ja das ist eine nervige
Situation für mich im Moment will ich
halt ständig im autofahr bin das ist
meistens me Part drum heißt Mama uber
thank you have a good one oh sich den
drucksack ab und den Jacke
ab
wowck robisu geht seit zi Monaten in den
Kindergarten Melanie fährt nicht direkt
nach Hause neuerdings muss sie einen
weiteren Stopp einplanen bei der Schule
von Lil Rose denn es gab einen
folgenreichen
Zwischenfall schulbusumfall ir ein so
schräg
Schulbus glücklicherweise hat sich Lil
Rose nicht verletzt nur seit dem Unfall
will sie sich nicht mehr in den Schulbus
setzen für sie ist einfach schlimm g
dass das Ganze Aufgebot oder die Polizei
und fürw und sie hat nicht gewüst was
passiert dann jetzt und und das ist für
sie schlimm geseh ja und jetzt hole ich
sie und bringe sie halt auch noch
ja für Melanie heißt das fast 3 Stunden
Autofahren am
Tag
[Musik]
ja hey
sek bye
bye und wie
[Musik]
H undgang ja
super 33° und Sonnenschein auf Mallorca
die Touristen genießen ihre
Ferien ganz anders
ma g in bresas delm der Gastronom aus
dem Kanton Luzern steckt mitten in der
arbeitsreichsten Phase der
Saison zusammen mit Partner Gabor
ballock ist er se Tage die Woche im
Restaurant die anfängliche Unsicherheit
von gastroneuling Gabor ist Routine
gewichen freiit das geft aber manchmal
ich möchte nicht
bedienen manchmal ich habe keine Lust
auf Menschen und ich möchte nur bar
machen mal das muss bezahlen ja der
gaslieferank und ein SPR und du muss
einfach immer Gasflasche stß für Stelle
der Weier
Hal und fragt wie viel Gasflasche das
und die mus Cash zah h du keine ein
hinten hat dem
Schrank seit ein paar Wochen ist OTM der
alleineige Chef Corina die das
Restaurant 10 Jahre lang führte hat sich
vorzeitig
zurückgezogen ja die letzte verhandle
sind extrem g mit der Gorin wir haben
alles noch müss klar und wir sind
eigentlich strinand hab aber
wiederfunden aber ich bin froh jetzt ist
Restaurant die mE zu 100% es ist alles
gelöst und erledigt den neuen
Pachtvertrag hat OTM gleich über 5 Jahre
abgeschlossen mit Option auf weitere 5
Jahre er glaubt fest an seine Vision des
brissers ich glaub mit dem H dass mir so
viel verändert sie das nicht erwartet
aber ich hat könen schaffen und das wird
noch viel mehr verändert es wird noch
viel meh denü da wden mir noch riguros
ren Veränderung bei der Einrichtung
Beständigkeit beim Personal gute
Mitarbeiter sind rar das weiß ma genau
ihnen trägt er daher besonders
Sorge so und jeder Morgen geht es fein
Kaffe und bes für die
Liebe
Kaffee
wenn wir
zze jetzt gerade ist schwierig dann
hab der 50-Jährige ist in seiner neuen
Rolle als Restaurantbesitzer angekommen
seine gesundheitlichen Probleme sind
Vergangenheit gesundheitlich fühle ich
mich gut war schön freizit für sich
selber mit Freud am Mittwoch wenn wir ja
fre Tag und einfach
Schnu so jetzt würde ich auch ger
schnell
m Kaffeepause aber muss
warten
mor
Gruppe ein weiterer arbeitsreicher Tag
mit vielen Gästen
beginnt
[Musik]
die Bauarbeiten in der Lodge stehen für
einmal still trotz engem Zeitplan
4500 Baumsetzlinge warten darauf
gepflanzt zu
werden die Bäumchen bezog Steff vom
Forstdienst aufforsten wird in Island
gefördert denn nur 2% der Landesfläche
sind
bewaldet
will sehen wie die Schweizer mit dem
Pflanzen
vorankommen und ob sie beim Setzen alles
richtig
machen
ne miten Fichten Lärchen und Pappeln
möchte ste ihren bereits bestehenden
Wald vergrößern nur die Pflänzchen
müssen innerhalb einer Woche im Boden
sein so lautet BCH
Vorgabe aber das
bring ich ich bin schon happy und
absolutf dass man so macht ichfund es
ist einfach jetzt Moment nicht
richtigunkt zum das
machen challeng für
irgendw aber ja se die H
[Gelächter]
seit Steff ist optimistisch dass sie das
Pflanzen rechtzeitig abschließen können
Isabel hingegen ist nicht so
sicher weg Finish me longer
in longer
ail
jetzt hab noch Luft sind sehr
froh fertig gepflanzt die übrigen
Bäumchen können
warten
schokokoland R Schokolade das muss nicht
das muss Schokolade
sein
[Musik]
sch
18 bis zu 250 Gerichte und Desserts
serviert die bras Crew Tag für
Tag
Umsatz bringen aber auch die
Getränke ein Kunde hat mjorkinischen
Kräuterlikör
bestellt ist zu wenig ein
Moment er sag der Zeit nicht so viel nur
für das das ist zu wenig das ist nur
weil kein Eis drin ist mach einfach rein
bitte es ist genau wie in der Karte
steht musst du
sagen wir müssen Geld
verdienen Gabor löst das Problem auf
seine Art mit einer Portion Leichtigkeit
den kleinen Disput hat auch
schon bald wieder
[Musik]
vergessen
mit dem Abendservice beginnt für garor
die stressigste Zeit des Tages ist so
viel und ich muss
konzentrieren über 10 Stunden ist Gabor
schon im Restaurant ich bin so
müde
extrem ich war schon bewusst damit dass
dein Restaurant ist so nicht
deine eine ruhige Arbeit aber das so so
streng ist das
nicht hingegen kann die Müdigkeit besser
wegstecken im hinteren Teil des
Restaurants hatte sich ein Büro
eingerichtet m im Betrieb ist es ihm am
wohlsten und das eigene Geschäft scheint
ihn zu
beflügeln vergich august mit letz Jahr
haben wir mehr als 15% Umsatz gemacht
also wir hab sehr gut geschafft derh wir
der juni
schwächer Vorjahr das kompensieren gut
Gefühl alsos hat
stimmt sind auf gutem Trend hoffen es
Gott so wier
immer super lecker danke schön schönen
Abend dan alles läuft nach Plan endlich
[Musik]
hallo 7 Uhr in der Früh in Florida eine
Familie die im Wild West Beach House
übernachtet hat checkt bereits
aus
ein paar Kilometer weiter inchopi sind
Marie und Melanie im
Stress sie bereiten ihr Motorboot vor
nicht für eine Strandhochzeit sondern
für den ersten Ausflug mit zahlenden
Gästen ja bist vne jetzt her Gott ja du
bist extrem nervös und fah schnell ja
sind ja wenn man dasim Stress macht
dann ja ist ein nicht so
optimal für Wohnwagen
denkt swiser oder in allem ist swissc
ja
[Musik]
in Alligator point beginnt Amanda mit
der Reinigung des Hauses
personalanstellen ist eine der Auflagen
die die Auswanderer für ihr
investorenvisum erfüllen
[Musik]
müssen
doch B jetzt
drum ja wenn da das nicht weg
ja die Frauen sind durch auf die
aufmerksam geworden es geht auf den W
River okay tchü
[Musik]
danke
melährtchigator im beachhaus nachsehen
ist wirklich alles bereit für neue
Gäste was
daemt irwi alles verschauen und für
[Applaus]
Ding fast ein Jahr haben Melan und Mario
an diesem Haus
gearbeitet sie haben das Dach erneuert
dieü setzt die Badezimmer modernisiert
einen Wasserschaden repariert und neuen
Boden
verlegt da hab extrem lang Bruch mit
Umbau und irgendwann haben wir dann auch
das Spaß D verloren also natürlich das
nicht schneller gegangen oder und dann
wo wir dann wirklich prxi werden für
zummerferieen wo dann Familie vor allem
in USA Feri h und
kommen ist noch
klimalang jetzt hoffen sie auf viele
Gäste trotz
[Musik]
Nebensaison zurück auf dem ur River der
nur 18 km lange Fluss entspringt aus
einer der größten Süßwasserquellen der
Welt
2 Zahlen die Frauen für die Tour dafür
möchte Mario ihnenas
turt wow
[Musik]
Love ist doch schön schaffen so auch
schaff aber to anders
vorher
geht sch also ich
B ger in der
Berge
und
momentan ja sind da sch die
Ecke Baby
[Musik]
wekü und
schildköten
das neue Leben der
[Musik]
charmas und dann entdeckt Mario auch
noch den ersehnten
[Musik]
Alligator Wasser ist auch in Island
Thema seit 6 Wochen hat es im Osten der
Insel kaum
geregnet die Trockenheit könnte zum
Problem für die Wasserversorgung der
Tiny Häuser werden steef kontrolliert
den Wasserstand der neuebauten
Quellfassung ja es
war 15 cm
höher wo Wasser ist halt extrem
troch noch ist der Tank mit 8000 l gut
gefüllt aber schon morgen werden die
ersten Gäste was
verbrauchen sage so in der Woche wird
den langsam knapp mit dem Wasser wo
momentan kommt und das ist halt
schneeschmerz schesen und kom ke Wasser
also das vom Himmel müsste jetzt wieder
hfen aber wen wir
[Musik]
mal mit der Erschließung derelle haben
diewe weitere Hürde beim Bau der
dreitiny Häuser
[Musik]
gemeistert mal aber aber
ja ist in in ja Nein Flüge aber
die ja
ja nach Monaten der plerei sind ste auf
der
zielgaden
oder
da die Hausordnung darf nicht
[Gelächter]
fehlen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
a
super wie find du
gut endlich ist alles fertig fast
[Musik]
alles auf Anfang
zurück mittwochs ist das brisersm
geschlossen dann haben alle frei die
Mitarbeiter und auch g
und endlich haben die beiden Auswanderer
Zeit zum
Entspannen sie wohnen jetzt im Zentrum
von
karajada nur 3 Minuten zu Fuß von mir
entfernt h ist viel besser viel
heller und viel also ich meine viel
farbiger und ein bisschen
moderner mehrmals schon sind sie mit
Hund Ronaldo umgezogen hier wollen sie
jetzt erstmal
bleiben hast gut
geschlafen
wenig du bist irendwie vollen zügenen
und du funktionierst doch machst t t t
und da bist du komst du he und du kan
nicht gerade schlafen ist einfach nch so
innerlich nervös also nervös einfach dem
Trin vom Restaurant ich nicht ich war
einfach mü und wenn man sehr müde kann
nicht schlafen
sofort die Tage im Restaurant sind lang
und während der Saison gibt es kaum
Freizeit tut das
gut seit ihrer Auswanderung verbringen
die beiden viel mehr Zeit miteinander
als zuvor ja das iststrengend wenn du
den ganz tagammen bist und no und
irgendein du auch Ruh von mir und ich
sehr gerne Ruh von
dir
so sehr gerne haben da eig Plan zwischen
wi immer Stund machen aber bis Gott das
gar nicht wen wir einfach Z wenig L sind
quasi und es läuft sehr gut und das got
jetzt Hal
nicht ich weiß nicht ob wirklich für
gabur Zukunft ist Gastronomie also muss
schon arbeiten das verstehe ich schon
aber nicht so am ganz früh am Morgen und
dann nur nach Hause dann nur am schlafen
und dann was mache
ich trotz gelegentlicher
Meinungsverschiedenheiten die beiden
bereuen es nicht den Schritt in ein
neues Leben gewagt zu haben Schwein
mitr Sonne und
Meer das haben sie sich erträumt und
gefunden auch wenn die Zeit zum Genießen
noch zu kurz
kommt das war für mich so eine kaltes
Wasser aber ich habe sehr viel gelernt
und ich möchte immer noch mitich
verbessern und einfach ich
wünsche Glück ja meine hen erlbt W
funktioniert es wird sicher ruhiger rein
von Organisation her aber was ich
natürlich hoffen ist dass
wi
und wir crazy Bar Tom und
[Musik]
Cher noch das ist fein hat mir
gefallen ihre Auswanderung war kein
Sonntagsspaziergang doch sie haben nie
aufgegeben in Florida gibt es einen
Grund zu feiern ein Jahr schon lebt
Familie Char im Sunshine State da typis
für
die Mario und Melanie haben ihre neuen
Freunde zum Grillfest
eingeladen Achtung
wie
scheiß ja das weiß ich hung mus ich
[Musik]
ma Familie hat neust in der Fremde
gewagt und
gewonnen
mit dem Geschäft und so und da da sen da
schlussendlich ist das fast
einfacher
erwartet
Hall 30 Gäste wollen mit den chers auf
ihre Auswanderung
[Musik]
anstoßen
auch Winky ist da die einztige
Besitzerin des
Wohnhauses für Melanie ist sie wie eine
Mutter denn melanys Eltern Leben schon
viele Jahre nicht
mehr
oh
[Musik]
so
ja das sind die momentente was schön
machen zum und zum ja wirklich einfach
[Musik]
gemacht
schneller als erwartet konnte Familie
charner Fuß
fassen ein Haus mit Pool ein großer
Freundeskreis und das eigene Business
die chas haben sich ihren amerikanischen
Traum
erfüllt die Tage allerdings sind voll
das D das Action die ganze Zeit und das
wirklich geht also wir sind nicht wo
sagen in Z Jahr machen wir denn das also
sind das to von elt dass
wir wenn W machen wir und zwar jetzt und
nicht wie aber dur das gbt viel
Situationen ziemlich
Stress
super
ft optim und das das
fllig ja halt Z fr wie hol und und auch
Geld fr h dass man
das wirkich gut wirtschaftlich betrieben
oder Traum ist dass wir da
wirklich bliben dürfen und und istes
Geschäft meh ausbauen dfen und diese
Idee wo mir im Kopf alle
verwklich
[Musik]
whats
[Applaus]
die Natur in Island hat sich für einmal
besonders schön herausgeputzt
tiny houseus Nummer 1 ist
fertig nthulius Nordlicht haben Isabel
und Steff es
[Musik]
getauft mit der Ankunft der ersten Gäste
kommt ihr anspruchsvolles Bauprojekt zum
[Musik]
Abschluss alles begann mit einer
Pauschalreise auf der sie ihre
Faszination für Island
entdeckten frisch vermält sind Isabel
und Steff vor etwas mehr als einem Jahr
mit einem Anhänger voller zügelkartons
in hergisville
gestartet ist body
mit Fleiß handwerklichem Geschick und
Ausdauer haben sie ihr gemeinsames
Projekt
verwirklicht stand g sind g sind
glücklich und mir
und ja dastsach
klar freizit war cool und so und eiglich
nur
schaff aber ich danke wenn du neuesbauen
mus einfach zerst Z jah mus hinen
und und G und wenn du W schon mal
g funktioniert nicht ich glaube nicht
dass ich le gemacht hat und ich bin da
sehr dankbar dafür dass
das dass man eigentlich da wirklich
Beich undich realisiert was ich
dichagt Gold Z Schwiz seit al wir fühl
da extrem wohl h sehr gut die Wurzel
geschlagen
bereits wenn es gut FL wo wo es wirklich
viel Energie geht wenn jetzt auch ir bis
komt ich glaube ich wer da bben bis
jetzt hab wir noch gar nicht und zurück
wir auch
nicht
[Musik]
se
auf und davon präsentiert von
Edelweiß